migration like on the border right
border patrol like close it down a
little bit like whatever but we don't
but it just keeps going more and more
people are realizing there is a problem
and that actually that's the key thing
at the moment right because a month ago
most people didn't realize there's a
problem now the fact that Greg Abbott
did this it escalated it into the
mainstream we got this bipartisan deal
it doesn't look like it's going to
happen but more people are talking about
what is obviously a problem I thought
this was interesting this is a professor
at Penn State University basically
explaining why the Democrats are trying
to overrun the country with illegals on
the B migration like on the border right
border patrol like close it down a
little bit like whatever but we don't
but it just keeps going and it makes me
think the people that are running the
shop must for some reason want to have
this unfettered immigration flow
including undocumented workers cuz
otherwise we would just pass a law that
says you can't do that like or we would
tell these like uh the the authorities
the people who would be deputized and
people are going to rent it to folks
like pick them up out the streets and do
something it's just bizarre to me that
we just let it happen and by we I mean
the people that are making the laws and
enforcing the laws because it's not the
three of us it's somebody else it's
people that are like holding the strings
up here and they don't
so we got this constant immigration flow
and we got about 11 million undocumented
workers in the United States right now
undocumented people all right so with
that Professor it's good to know that
there are still some Sayan professors at
some Sayan universities what he's saying
is that there is a giant multinational
shell game being played right now we are
moving people all over the globe we are
moving people all across borders and you
cannot pretend it is not intentional
right so you don't have to think uh that
Joe Biden is doing intentionally cuz we
don't know who's I mean every literally
everybody in this town that you talk to
nobody thinks he's running the show
everyone knows it you don't think he's
running the show I don't think Dr Jill
Biden thinks he's running the show etc
etc we all get that but the point is it
has to be intentional at this point you
know there were a lot of people for
months and months oh well you know it's
like the Democrats like immigrants more
and you know whatever and then and then
more and more people have realized as
you just see thousands of people Rampage
through the Border again they're always
fighting age it's always men 25 to 35
where are the women where are the old
old people etc etc then you start
realizing oh whoever is in charge
whoever is pulling those strings to C
reference they actually want this and
the question is do they want this
because they just want our cities to be
overrun and our services destroyed so
they can usher in some some new system
do they want it so that you get all of
these people on the Dole and once you're
on the doll you end up voting for
Democrats pretty much forever see black
people in America that probably is it
that probably is
it